ذكرت صحيفه اسرائيليه ان وزير الامن
القومي الاسرائيلي اتمار بن غفير امر
الشرطه بالاستمرار في تنفيذ عمليات هدم
الوحدات السكنيه للفلسطينيين التي وصفها
بغير القانونيه في القدس الشرقيه خلال شهر
رمضان وقال صحيفه ان تحرك بن غفير ياتي
على الرغم من اتخاذ قرار بمنع هدم الابنيه
غير القانونيه بحسب القانون الاسرائيلي في
القدس الشرقيه خصوصا خلال فتره رمضان لمنع
اثاره التوتر هذا وادانا السلطه
الفلسطينيه تصريحات الوزير الاسرائيلي
التي وصفتها بانها تحرض على المزيد من
تصعيد الاوضاع في ساحه الصراع وحملت
السلطه الفلسطينيه الحكومه الاسرائيليه
برئاسه نتنياهو المسؤوليه الكامله
والمباشره عن الانتهاكات المتواصله في
القدس مؤكده ان وقت جميع الاجراءات احاديه
الجانب غير القانونيه هو المدخل للالتزام
بتفهمات العقبه ووقف التصعيد الاسرائيلي
المتواصل
[تصفيق]